as a contribution uh to public life
which uh all of us I think as we assess
can can consider as one which has been
uh significant and all of us can be
grateful for the good that Boris did
while he was in office yeah but it's
about the dummy on Friday and talked
about kangaroo courts I mean hardly
appropriate behavior from a former prime
minister well Boris will have his own
recollection and I'm not asking him
you're sat in front I'm asking you I
know and uh the critical thing I think
is uh it's a properly constituted
Committee of the House of Commons with
distinguished and experienced MPS on it
neither of us have yet read the report
so we'll have to wait and see and and
you know pass judgment on it later but
no I I wouldn't describe uh the
committee as a kangaroo court not at all